americans we love ice cream
each person eats about 24 quarts of it
per year
and that's for one big reason it tastes
amazing
but someone had to teach ben jerry's how
to do it turns out that guy he works at
penn state
this is dr bob
robert hold on
okay this is dr bob roberts he teaches
ice cream courses at penn state i do
i have two courses
ice cream short course and ice cream 101
side note these are the type of books
ice cream professors read
okay back to the story part of the
reason
that ice cream is so good in the us is
that we've been teaching ice cream for
125 years and bob he's been teaching at
penn state for 25 of those and he's had
some pretty famous students
companies like unilever nestle breyer's
ben and jerry's
you name the company they've sent people
here that's because the penn state
creamery is on the forefront of ice
cream technology ice cream is a
formulated food there is no naturally
occurring ice cream you have to put the
ingredients together and process it to
make ice cream
bob and his department they spend their
time figuring out how to make ice cream
even better when we look at studying ice
cream we study ice cream from cow to the
cone so we look at what happens on the
farm what happens with the milk wait
there's a farm we have a herd of about
250 or so milking holsteins and yes they
are on campus
so yeah he knows ice cream
but he says that he's not an ice cream
purist
i'm not sure what an ice cream purist is
but i wouldn't eat frozen yogurt if i
had the opportunity to eat ice cream
yeah well that does make sense
considering he is the authority on ice
cream bob what's your favorite flavor
hmm dulce de leche oh yeah
you